I do have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p let's
take a listen to a voicemail that came
in i'm not a well educated person but
what happened peculiar in politics and
religion is the greater the lie the more
warmly it is embraced mmm yeah this is a
comment relating to what we were
discussing yesterday about Donald Trump
told 34 lives during the first debate
Hillary Clinton told six lies during the
first debate yet Donald Trump is by and
large seen as more honest and
trustworthy Donald Trump accuses other
people of lying and uh yet lying lying
is an unusual thing and it can have
unpredictable and sometimes illogical
effects on people who hear the lies on
today's bonus show we have started to
see ads seeking uh uh female students
from sugar daddies on the University of
New Hampshire campus we're going to talk
about that we're also going to talk
about we did a story a while ago about
something called shade balls in
California which were uh an experimental
method of saving water it turns out that
it has worked and we're going to talk
about that on the bonus show and much
more you can sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership